[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i know it was weird i was wondering like
what was that i thought it was
like everything was darker in here yeah
yeah i was like damn dude i'm rather
racist bro
but now i realize i had these on i'm
sorry at a certain point can having sex
like endanger you if it like gets your
heart real hot
you know but i would rather die that way
i wouldn't i'd rather die chilling out
dude on a [ __ ] couch watching [ __ ]
jeopardy
yeah you're on a couch and you go here
it does
and then you're done right but imagine
right having like
being like uh who's that playboy guy
hugh hefner hugh hefner right
lining up nine women and then the third
one
you have a heart attack oh yeah the way
to go bruh playing like russian hulette
right yeah yeah yeah and also at that
age no condom you don't give a [ __ ] bro
oh dude
at any age no i mean who's even are they
still making condoms that's what i want
to know
for old people for people yeah they
still use it
i haven't heard and no one's even
getting anything anymore
in any other time period yeah you and i
would have been like schindler
really yeah we would help people i think
i feel like i would have to do a lot of
the work and you would have been kind of
kind of complaining off to the side
but i think so what you're saying is if
we were nazi german you and i are german
and we want to help some jews yes and
we're trying to smuggle 50 out of a camp
that i would carry two and you carry 48.
i think i'd be put in charge of more of
them yeah that's so
[ __ ] rude that's so rude
well here's what he hears no no i'm
gonna say this dude okay all right
i would probably not do as much as you
okay
but i would do a lot of work you're
looking at me when you said
no because you you gave me a look like
you doubt me here's the thing i'd put
you in charge of the snacks i would be
in charge of
leading us leading us a direction you'd
be in charge of the
the bread bag and something else yes
guys leg and he's hopping up and down
you're like yeah dan's vietnamese
dude you make it sound like a condiment
dude yeah yeah i love the fries and the
uh vietnamese on them
if you squirt a little more vietnamese
on those have you ever been involved in
like drug-induced homosexuality
you know like where people do enough
drugs that somebody's gay so
i've done it
bro you already know
you already [ __ ] know i don't know
dude i'm thinking if i know or not and i
don't you
you don't know that i've sucked the dick
before whoa
[ __ ] bro put your hand in the air before
you say that
take my headphones all right man [ __ ]
dude and make these guys
do them dude make these whites in here
[ __ ] grow them [ __ ] i might have
everyone and even the [ __ ] gooks in
here too right
yeah some of the i don't know i don't
know who is a [ __ ] but yeah
yeah yeah no idea bro very good
i feel like you've said that word before
bro i mean i've said it i just don't
know who it's at
that's the problem dude that's not a
problem that's really the benefit you
know but i'll tell you why the
mahabharat because um
you know my people i don't know if you
know my people but you know i don't know
who's
the phoebe yeah steve yeah and also a
billion other [ __ ] people
yeah yeah that's a lot of people bro
i've seen a lot of people sleeping in
the airport
but imagine sucking him off i'm not
sucking anybody dude i might bang the
guy
i'm not blowing some dude bro that's the
gayest thing ever oh let me ask you
something what
would it take for you to blow somebody
i wouldn't do it for okay so let me ask
you this then
okay right jesus came down
oh christ okay now i'm not saying
blowing cry i'm not gonna say that okay
no would you blow christ
it would you blow christ no okay good
even if you're gonna be an attorney in
hell
dude i'm not i'm not blowing anybody so
all right he's the lord but fine on your
podcast
we talked about how you can't tell us a
different tell us apart
asians that's not true i know he's from
laos
i know but if you saw him in this like
there was other five other laos guys
would you go oh that's that dude from
tiger belly or you'd be like no that's
five laos guys
i'm like that's the guy from the cruise
first of all that's the same thing
everybody does on the show
like bro if you had a tag a nametag said
rico on it you get [ __ ] all the time
if mankind was all gonna die i would
suck whoever
not whoever i'd suck the guy who is most
qualified to help us save the
the universe right in america i'm not
blowing something outside
because he's scared about what's going
on as well yeah yeah you know
yeah yeah but i like your attitude
you've never done anything gay in your
life
uh i've never done anything gay man they
had a time where i think a dude was
trying to get me to be
gay one time and i had to go to the
airport and we've been
and we've been doing cocaine and so i'm
glad i had to go to the airport man
because
that's the thing at a certain point
there can be drug-induced homosexuality
so i'm in this tunnel there are cars
whizzing by here's the crazy thing
yeah extremely hard to poop when cars
are going by
50 60 70 miles an hour and furious too
yeah furious like and also white people
like it was pittsburgh so it's furious
white people driving by
i can if other people are some certain
ethnicities i can [ __ ] easier when
they're driving by honestly
you know like if a couple of brothers
are rolling by blasting some [ __ ]
good music i can [ __ ] blow ass all
day into a frisbee
no problem part of you know everything
is everybody's you know everybody seems
like it's
more laid back yeah yeah but angry white
dudes you know rolling by
you know six seven well they would
probably call somebody too huh
oh they weren't calling anybody i mean
the only free finger they had they were
waving it out the window
yeah they weren't using it to dial the
phone so you [ __ ] on a frisbee out of
[ __ ] in the open
now the yeah not the top part but the
bottom part a frisbee is basically a cup
basically the size oh a plate it's a
plate a plate
well a plate is just a cup that's ways
hang on are you a plate is just a wide
wide white cup
or you pulled over well i pulled it yeah
i pulled over the car i think honestly
i'd run out again
on the ground why did you have to be
like underneath yeah so it's dark [ __ ]
on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] in a tunnel you play this [ __ ]
okay you should be familiar with tunnels
dude why huh
because of vietnam because you're gonna
do that [ __ ] again right now man what's
the [ __ ] bro
why are you why you oh no oh no dude
right you're doing that nom [ __ ] again
huh bro what number
you thought that i was digging tunnels
in the ho chi minh trail and trying to
attack you people
no i thought you meant that the fruit
juice the pomegranate fruit juice that's
always in there
palm yeah no no dude no
not pom nom bro i don't believe in
vietnam i don't believe it and it
happened are you those uh they never
found the boats dude
oh right it's just like slavery they
never found the boats
what do you mean tunnels though bro so
anyway i'm in a tunnel i'm in a tunnel
and there's only two lanes going each
way there's no there's nowhere to get
out in the tunnel
like in a tunnel you know cars are
whizzing by
yeah and so i had to get in the back
seat and defecate into this frisbee
right
and um and then wait for the cops to
come
why would you call the car had to call
the cops
somebody i i well somebody not somebody
i had just [ __ ] in a frisbee in my car
and i needed help yeah
there's a lot of things i didn't learn
from that story
i'll tell you what i didn't learn okay
say something i didn't learn
that um a frizz a cup a cup and a plate
are the same [ __ ] thing they're not
the same thing
depends on the aspens on who where you
are
how strong the gravity is in an area how
fresh the cup how recently you made it
how how warm is the clay a [ __ ] cup
is just a plate is just a wide wide cup
the sides can't get along
that's all it is that's the truth dude
wow
go beat a plate apart with a hammer and
then tape it together
and don't do a good job would a bowl be
the same as a
as a as a plate go beat a cup apart i'm
sorry with the hammer
that's true you flatten it out maybe
they're tape it together
right what do you have you have a
[ __ ] plate there you got a plate
and you [ __ ] wonder you're i don't
know how you're doing dude
you're crafty dude huh [ __ ] mate man
would you say chickpea
i wouldn't say [ __ ] i said checkmate i
heard
i heard chickpeas set me up for racial
[ __ ]
i saw you in love though and i thought
you did a good job i don't need it
whatever you're doing right now i don't
need it you're right i know i know what
i do
i'm pandering not that you're pandering
i don't even know
i don't really believe it i don't know i
don't know that i don't believe here
and it's not like i'm not pandering yeah
yeah i'm pandering
yeah but what i'm saying if i were
pandering and i just [ __ ] show you a
picture of a panda on my wrist yeah
but you would like it though can i slip
a little dang sunflower seed up there
for it hmm
inside of my butt you'd feed the worm to
bait it or i mean if i was
young and i you know cared about animals
and stuff yeah i bet i would
you know get you a little you know a
little cinnamon stick or something just
you know give it a little one of those
good and plenty you ever had one of them
what's a good one it's a candy small
shaped candy
you probably wouldn't even feel it in
your into your butt you know yeah
but oh but it oh
a good and plenty i've never heard of it
the candy so um let me just ask you some
questions about this one
purple one all right i can't see i've
never had oh so it's not chocolate based
no i wouldn't do that okay so go to them
you think i'm a damn school shooter
oh man yeah like i'm on a sitcom now
yeah
and i just speak regular like everyone
else
is it good somebody said it's not any
good
who said that huh yeah when i wanted my
clothes for you yeah
crack i wouldn't do crack oh yeah i
never got to smoke crack and
i feel like i wish i would have
cracked seems yeah i see how one can
probably want to get into crap yeah
yeah but you know yeah yeah yeah
dude my [ __ ] was always hiding behind
something smoking
i think i could see us two in a burnout
building
like doing that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah snakes flanka
it's way too much for me yeah because
what if you need your buddy what if he
has the [ __ ] directions to somewhere
you gotta do a couple hits
you [ __ ] next you know you come too
and you [ __ ] ate half of your buddy
yeah and you're thinking i can't get to
bakersfield yeah i was gonna go to
bakersfield i knew that yeah jesus man
yeah i'm never gonna be able to find my
ipod anymore
[ __ ] this guy yeah you know he's on tv
and uh
you know like i mean i'm polish
nicaragua yeah
some people wanted a gun and some people
wanted the pipe
that's what i heard anyway it was like
the dodgers really wanted to party you
and i
you're a pipe guy or fight guy back then
i'd probably load my gun with a couple
grams and just shoot them right at my
[ __ ] nose bubba
i think i'm somewhere in the middle yeah
whenever i see like movies on woodstock
or anything like that
i just knew no i would i died yeah
just the way i did it even without like
outside i did it in a different era
yeah drugs and alcohol and i did it so
hard
that i could i'd probably be just be
dead
underneath jim morrison's dead body in a
bathtub
you know and then why is that asian guy
i don't know man he was just there yeah
he was there man he was on a bike
in trying to sell a bicycle and then he
overdosed so love is in the air you guys
have been lovers for how long
and this is her sixth six years of
loving wow
together and when was the first time
that you guys if it's okay to talk about
it when was the first time you guys had
sexual intercourse
um probably two months no that's not
true a month into our relationship
but he had to drive i mean to long beach
every day
did you really yeah i went she she
didn't even come into my place for a
month did he uber did he drive
i drove to [ __ ] long beach every day
i'm asking
the woman he drove down there he did and
what would he do his filth either he
didn't try to
he didn't try he didn't clean his car he
had piles of like bottles and just
dirty underwear everything dad bro it's
so gross
but i was like okay well i i respect
that this is his baseline and he's not
trying to
front like he's anybody else oh that's
pretty cool yeah
so there was no bait and switch huh
mm-hmm
[Music]
there are a few but more of a
more of a maybe an effort thing not
really a cleanliness thing
from the get-go i knew he was a he was a
pig hiding you know
hygiene wise he was a hygiene risk they
called it yeah yeah for sure hepatitis
risk
oh yeah yeah definitely wow
are you a sleeper away i had to get my
booster shot did you really yeah
oh definitely yeah he seemed like that
guy uh who's definitely got that fever
in him
you know he's got the potential for uh
he's got the potential for fever
liver fever oh if you look i couldn't
even imagine seeing one of his blood
cells under a microscope
who would even know it's probably just
sitting there [ __ ] vaping you know
um so you guys the full one month then
you guys got into sex now how did that
kind of start cause i'm
where was the first date let's cause i
just want to learn about love it's
valentine's i want to learn about
y'all's love
we can talk about love what are you
did i feel like i'm on a yellow mirror
have you seen that show
bro bro yellow mirror
yeah it was very good and
i wouldn't give you i wouldn't give you
more of a laugh
if i wasn't so enraged right now i'm
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
just the wrong way